بدا الائتلاف الوطني السوري الذي اعلن عنه
في العاصمه القطريه وجمع غالبيه الاطياف
والتيارات السياسيه المعارضه للنظام في
دمشق بدا مساعيه على المستوى العربي لنيل
الاعتراف به ممثلا للشعب
السوري
[موسيقى]
نتوقف مشاهدينا مع هذا الخبر لنناقش في
عنوانين رئيسيين اولا ما هي المهمات
الرئيسيه والتحديات التي تنتظر هذا
الائتلاف ثم هل سيحظى هذا الائتلاف
باعتراف المجتمع الدولي
[موسيقى]
وبدعم
التقى اذا احمد معاد الخطيب رئيس الائتلاف
الوطني السوري بالامين العام لجامعه الدول
العربيه نبيل العربي في مقر الجامعه
العربيه بالقاهره يهدف هذا التحرك الى نيل
اعتراف الجامعه العربيه بالائتلاف كممثل
للشعب السوري لا سما وان الجامعه كانت
جمدت عضويه دمشق فيها العام الماضي وكان
من اول المعترفين بالائتلاف دول مجلس
التعاون الخليجي اذا هل سينجح الكيان
الجديد للمعارضه السوريه في نيل مزيد من
الاعتراف
دوليا هل يقرب الائتلاف الوطني السوري
المعارضه اكثر من اي وقت مضى من هدف بدا
بعيدا وهو الحديث بصوت واحد للحصول على
القبول الداخلي والاعتراف الدولي العلامات
الاولى تشير صوب نوع من التفاؤل احمد معاذ
الخطيب رئيس الائتلاف الوطني السوري يزور
مقر جامعه الدول العربيه حيث المقعد
السوري شاغر بعد تعليق عضويه دمشق السنه
الماضيه قطر تتحدث بلهجه الواثق عن اعتراف
عربي ودولي قادم بالائتلاف وحكومه يشكلها
في المنفى بالعمل على مستوى الجامعه
العربيه ومجلس التعاون الخليجي ومع
الاوروبيين والامريكيين يصبح الائتلاف هو
الممثل الشرعيه للشعب السوري لن يتم الامر
بالاجماع على الارجح لان دولا عربيه عرفت
بمعارضتها تغيير النظام في سوريا من دون
اجماع قد يحل الموضوع بالتصويت بالاكثر ان
تحققت الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا ترحبان
بميلاد الائتلاف السوري الجديد وفرنسا تعد
بالسعي للحصول على الاعتراف الدولي به لم
يسبق المعارضه السوريه ان حققت خطوه كهذه
منذ 20 شهرا ولم يسبق ان سحبت دوله
اعترافها بالنظام في سوريا بغض النظر عن
حده انتقاداتها له لكن كيف اذا برهنت
المعارضه السوريه على انها بديل جاهز تعرف
السلطه احيانا بانها هي الحق في الامر
والنهي سيكون مطلوبا من الائتلاف السوري
مثلا ان يفرض سلطته السياسيه على كافه
الفصائل والمجموعات المسلحه المعارضه
ويتحكم بدخول السلاح واستخداماته وتطبيق
القوانين الدوليه المتعلقه بحمايه
المدنيين والاسرى لا سما ان انظار منظمات
حقوقيه دوليه مركزه اكثر فاكثر على الثوار
السوريين وينضم الينا الان مع معنا
بالاستديو حسان الهاشمي عضو الائتلاف
الوطني السوري ومعنا من مقر اجتماعات
المعارضه السوريه عفوا معنا هنا بالاستديو
انضمت الينا كان يفترض ان تكون معنا من
مقر الاجتماعات ولكن شكرا لتفضل بالمشاركه
معنا من داخل الاستديو السيده سهير
الاتاسي ومعنا من واشنطن مارك جوبن استاذ
دراسات تسويه النزاعات في جامعه جورج مسون
نرحب بضيوفنا جميعا ابدا معك سيده سهير
الاتاسي الان ولد هذا الائتلاف تشكل
والحمد لله واتفق الجميع وتوحدت المعارضه
اخيرا ما هي الان اهم المهمات الرئيسيه
امام هذا الائتلاف هلا بعتقد انه التحدي
الاساسي رح يكون امام امام هذا الائتلاف
هو تشكيل جسم تنفيذي
يعني الثوره كانت الاشكاليه الكبيره فيها
هي هي عباره عن تعدد قنوات الدعم يعني حتى
حتى الدول كانت تعتمد كل دوله عن دوله
مجموع تفرق عن مجموعه اخرى وبذلك ساهمت
حتى بالدعم الاغاثي وحتى البعض عندما دعم
دعم عسكري بشكل عشوائي ساهمت بتقسيم الارض
فانا اجد ان وحده هذه المعارضه والاهم هو
وجود ثقل حقيقي وفعلي داخل هذا الائتلاف
لقوى الحراك الثوري ولدينا ايضا يعني انه
مندوبي المجالس المحليه ممثلي المجالس
المحليه فاجد الان التحدي الاكبر هو كيف
يكون هناك جسم تنفيذي يمر عبر عره وعبره
فقط يعني انا كنت ادعو الى اغلاق دكاكين
الثوره بالتاكيد هناك دكاكين يعني لكل
ثوره هناك دكاكين اغلاق هذه الدكاكين من
قبل الدول واعتماد هذا الجسم التنفيذي لكي
يمر الدعم الاغاثي وفي وقت قريب ايضا
العسكري وعبر هذا الجسم يمكننا فعلا توحيد
الارض وتنظيم الارض وبذلك يمكن تغيير
موازين القوى في الداخل طيب لتغلق هذه
الدكاكين كما سميتها الدكاكين الحرب او
كين امراء الحرب يجب ان يكون هناك جسم
واحد ممثل شرعي ووحيد للشعب السوري لكن
يجب ان يكون هناك اعتراف دولي بهذا
الائتلاف والسؤال لك استاذ حسان الهاشمي
هل تتوقع ان ياتي الاعتراف سريعا بهذا
الكيان
الجديد الحقيقه هو هذا هو السؤال الصعب
انا في تقديري ان المعارضه السوريه بكل
اطيافها وبكل يعني ثورتها ومسيرتها التي
يعني استمرت طوال الفتره الماضيه عانت
وعملت بما بوسعها طبعا هي كانت في حال لا
تحسد عليها السؤال الصعب الان الاختبار
الحقيقي هو عند المجتمع الدولي المجتمع
الدولي الان هو في حاله اختبار انا اعتقد
الان الكره هي تماما في الملعب في الطرف
الاخر من الملعب ليست في طرف المعارضه
السوريه الان الملعب الغربي في الملعب
الغربي نعم اي وال يعني كما يقولون نريد
ان نرى ما كان يعني يقال
وعودا بالكلام ينفذ حقيقه واقعه لدينا
تحفظات كثيره على طريقه تعامل المجتمع
الدولي مع مع الموضوع السوري في عمومه طيب
هذا سؤال مهم استاذ حسان معنا معنا من
واشنطن مارك جوين يعني وعود ووعود وكلام
وكلام وكانت دائما كان واشنطن والغرب بشكل
عام يتحجج بان هذه المعارضه معارضه متشرد
مشتته غير موحده ها هي اليوم قد توحدت
لماذا جاء الترحيب بار دون اعتراف سريع
بهذا
الائتلاف استاذ ماروين
تسمعنا في
الحقيقه اعتقد ان هذا الامر جديد جدا ويجب
ان يكون هناك وقت بالنسبه للتوافق على هذا
التمثيل حسب تقديري الاعتراف ات لان هذه
المجموعه
حسب كلامي و محادثاتي مع زملائي في سوريا
هذا امر كانت
تنتظره الوزيره كلينتون اي مجموعه مهتمه
بحكم سوريا استنادا الى ائتلاف شامل
ديمقراطي يهتم بالمدنيين ويحافظ على
حقوقهم اذا انطباعي بان هذا الاعتراف هو
ات لا محاله لان قياده هذه المجموعه
حقا تسطر صفحه جديده في المعارضه ومستقبل
القياده السوريه المستقبليه يعني واشنطن
ستعترف بهذا الائتلاف ممثلا شرعيا ووحيدا
للشعب السوري هذا ما
تقوله انا اقول باني اعتقد بان البوادر
اتيه من الغرب ومن الولايات المتحده بان
تشارك مع هذه المجموعه بعمق وامل مبدئيا
بتقديم مساعدات انسانيه كبيره وتوفير
حمايه للمدنيين وتحرك جدي نحو ذاك النوع
من الاعتراف الذي يبعث رساله واضحه الى
نظام الاسد بانه انتهى وان عليه ان ينتقل
الى مرحله انتقاليه وكلما كانت هذه
المجموعه اكثر تمثيلا كما راينا من
الخطابات المم تزه بالامس التي ركزت على
الديمقراطيه وحقوق الانسان وعلى شموليه
هذه المجموعات كل هذه السبل اعتقد ان
الوزيره كلينتون ووزاره الخارجيه والبيت
الابيض مهتمون بها وهم لا يريدون ان
يرتكبوا ذات الاخطاء في افغانستان او
العراق لا يريدون ان يستثمروا بمجموعه
واحده فاسده ولكن بمجموعه تمثل سوريا ومن
ثم سيلقي بثقل وراء هذه مجموعه ويدعمها
سيلقي بثقتهم وراء هذا الكيان يقول مارك
جوين ان صدقت تنبؤاته يقول الوعود بلا
اعتراف بهذا الائتلاف قادمه ان شاء الله
لكن سيده سهير التاسي الان هذا التركيز
على الاعتراف الدولي والخارج والغرب
وامريكا يجعلنا نتساءل ان كان هذا
الائتلاف اليوم هو مصلحه غربيه مصلحه
خارجيه ام هو مصلحه حقيقيه واقعيت هم
الداخل السوري اكثر هلا وانا ايضا يعني
يعني وهذه حقيقه يعني انا الان اقول حقائق
حصلت هذه المبادره يعني بدات مجموعه سوريه
وعلى راسها رياض سيف بدات بالعمل على هذه
على هذه المبادره منذ اربع شهور تقريبا اي
ضمن مجموعه صغيره جدا
سوريه يعني تماما كان الاساس في هذه
المبادره هو العمل لصالح السوريين كان
الاساس في هذه المبادره كيف يمكن ان يصبح
هناك جسم يمثل هذه الثوره والاهم من ذلك
ينظم هذه الثوره يعني حتى الان ليس هناك
حتى خطاب ثوري واضح لهذه الثوره ليس هناك
جسم واحد اغاثي ي يمر عبره اغاثه هذه
الثوره فكان هذا هو همنا هلا باعتقادي هذا
الجسم والذي يملك الحراك الثوري اكثر من
الثلث في هذا الجسم وهذا موضوع غايه في
الاهميه باعتقادي وهذا ما طلبن به البارحه
وما سمعنا اليوم عن القبول بهذا بهذا
الطلب طالبنا بانه
كمبادرة تجربه سناخذ خلال ايام ليست بعيده
كثيرا اعتقد اننا سننجح الائتلاف الائتلاف
قادر على ذلك على كل ما ذكرته الان السيده
سهير الاتاسي على حل كل هذه المسائل وهل
هو فعلا هذا الائتلاف يخاطب الداخل اكثر
مما هو جاء نتيجه يعني ولاده بسبب ضغوط
خارجيه التي
دائما الغرب دائما يدعو المعارضه الى
التوحد هل توحدت اليوم من اجل تنظيم العمل
في الداخل وانجاح الثوره السوريه ربما
السؤال الرئيسي اليوم انه لماذا ذا اخترا
اسلامي معتدل على راس هذا الائتلاف قد لا
ينظر الغرب بعين الرضا الى اختيار شخصيه
اسلاميه على راس ائتلاف هل يهمكم مخاطبه
الداخل اكثر من
الخارج هو طبعا باستمرار يهمنا ان مخاطبه
الداخل اكثر من الخارج لكن انا
دعيني يعني اتوقف قليلا
عند يعني هذا الضغط الموجود على الثوره
وعلى المعاض باستمرار في فيما يتعلق
بالدور المطلوب منها وفيما تقوم به وما
والحال الذي وصلت اليه بالنسبه لمواضيع
الشرذمه و عدم توحيد الجسم الاغاثه مثلا
والقضايا اللي من هذا النوع نحن جميعا
نعلم ان هذه القضايا لم تاتي فقط بسبب عدم
تمكن الثوره والمعضل من تنظيم صفوفها هذه
قضايا ايضا كان سببها ممارسات سلبيه جدا
من من المجتمع الدولي في طريقه التعاطي مع
الثوره نحن نعلم جميعا كيف كان فيه هناك
تعامل منفرد مع مع مع مع مدن وحيانا حتى
مع قرى نحن نعلم تماما كيف انه في بعض
الدبلوماسيين ذهبوا الى داخل سوريا يوزعوا
اموال باكياس اموال الى الى بعض القرى هذه
قضايا غير مقبوله اطلاقا على الصعيد
الوطني كان في هناك اجسام وطنيه وكان ممكن
تمرير هذه المعونات عن طريقها فهذه الشرد
التي وصلنا اليها في كثير من الحالات لم
يكن الذنب فيها على على الثوره وعلى
المعارضه كان في هناك ايضا لها اسباب اخرى
اليوم نحن ونحن يعني دخلنا في هذه المرحله
الجديده ومتفائلين ومتعاونين نقول وبكل
ثقه اننا كما كنا بالامس عندنا الرغبه
الاكيده بالتعاون وبتنفيذ هذا العمل
الوطني
الواحد نقول ايضا انه اذا استمرت في
الممارسات الدوليه بنفس الصوره التي كانت
عليها في السابق فلن لن يتغير الحال حقيقه
اما اذا تغيرت هذه الممارسه ولذلك انا
اريد ان اشير ايضا الى الكلام الذي جاء من
ضيفك من واشنطن اها حول انا يعني لفت
انتباهي كيف هناك تلكؤ في التعبير
واستخدام الكلمات في قضيه الوصول الى
الاعتراف بهذه بهذا الائتلاف كممثل شرعي
ووحيد يعني هناك عمل من اجل الوصول الى
هذه قضايا معناتها ستاخذ شهرين وثلاث
بمعنى ان الائتلاف عليه ان يفرض نفسه اولا
في الواقع امحان
رب
لتاتي لياتي الاعتراف به لاحقا هذا لا
نختلف انا فقط اريد ان اوضح انه هذا لن
نختلف حوله الاتلاف بدون شك يجب ان يثبت
موجود ويثبت يعني جديه على الارض لكن هذه
القضيه لا تحتاج شهور هذه قضيه يعني تتضح
خلال فتره قصيره ونتمنى ان يكون في هناك
اعتراف مباشره بعد ذلك اذا كيف سيدعم هذا
ائتلاف الثوره السوريه نواصل النقاش بعد
وقت فه قصيره فلا تذهبوا
بعيدا
مشاهدينا نعود الى حلقتنا التي تناقش
ولاده الائتلاف السوري بعد اجتماعات لايام
عديده في الدوحه انتقل مره اخرى الى ضيفي
في واشنطن مارك جوين كنت تستمع السيد مارك
جوين الى ضيفنا حسن الهاشمي كان يقول ان
يعني شعر في في لهجتك شيئا من التعبير عن
تلكؤ في
المضي نحو عمليه الاعتراف بهذا الائتلاف
الجديد ما هي حقيقه المخاوف والتحفظات
التي تكبح الغرب في مساله الاعتراف بهذا
الائتلاف انا اعتقد ان ما يجري في الداخل
هو تحليل حذر
لدرجه التماس في هذا الائتلاف وان يفي
بالوعود ومن يمثل واعتقد ان هذه خطوه صحيه
كما انني اعتقد ان هناك وجهين للمساعده
والتدخل الاول عسكري والثاني انساني وان
اتفق مع
الضيف في الدوحه بانه في
الحقيقه من المسؤول جدا للمجتمع الدولي ان
يقدم المساعده ويتدخل لاننا بيننا
انقسامات فيما بين الدول الكبيره بالنسبه
للمساعده ما الذي سيحدث في المستقبل وما
ينبغي هو ان تكون هذه المجموعه تثبت بانها
ملتزمه بالحاجات المدنيه داخل سوريا وخارج
سوريا وان تقوم
بالمطالبه باسم هذه المجموعات للمجتمع
الدولي بان يتحرك وان يفي بهذه الوعود
وهذه المطالب رئيسيه وهذا سيرسل رساله
سريعه بان هذه المجموعه مسؤوله وستكون
مسؤوله عن الحكم المستقبلي لسوريا هذا
الامر الذي يريده الغرب والولايات المتحده
لا احد يريد ان يرى مجموعه ضعيفه ولا
مجموعه تعتني بنفسها لوحدها واعتقد ان
معلوماتي هي ان قياده هذه المجموعه جيده
جدا
والناس في البيت الابيض
سيعملون مع هذه المجموعه وبالنسبه لنوع
المساعده وكيف ستوزع واوجه التعاون هذا
يستغرق وقتا وهذه المحركات تتحرك ببطء
ولكن اعتقد على مدى الاسبوع القادم او
القادمين سيكون هناك تحرك سريع يصب في هذا
الاتجاه طيب استاذه سهير الاتاسي يعني
واضح من الكلام ان الغرب والولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ينتظرون ان يثبت هذا
الائتلاف نفسه على الارض ان يفرض سيطره
هل هو قادر على ذلك حتى يحصل على الاعتراف
الدولي هلا بالتاكيد هو قادر لماذا هو
قادر لان الجسم الاساسي فيه هو تماما جسم
الحراك الثوري الحراك الثوري اثبت خلال
الفتره الماضيه يعني وعي عالي واثبت انه
هناك ايضا شبكات اغاث يعمل هو من خلالها
وتقريبا يمكن الثوره السوريه وقفت لوحدها
على ارجلها من تبرعات السوريين وفقط
السوريين خلال سنه واكثر من سنه واط ان
توصل المواد الاعاشه والغذائيه حتى داخل
المدن المحاصره ولكن ما اريد ان اقوله
لضيفك الكريم انه يعني لا اعلم لماذا
دائما نشعر وكاننا نحن في موقع الاختبار
طب نحن ايضا نختبر الان موقف المجتمع
الدولي انا لا اعتقد ان المجتمع الدولي هو
بانتظار يعني جسم قيادي فعلا يعني قادر
على فرض السيطره على الارض السوريه من اجل
ان يغيث من اجل ان يبدا بالغث تجاه شعب
الان هو يباد الان هناك يعني فعلا حمله
اباده على على هذا الشعب نحن نعلم وفعليا
هذه ايضا كانت ماساه هم نفسهم الذين
طالبونا خلال فترات طويله واشهر طويله بان
تتوحد هذه المعارضه هم انفسهم كانوا
متفرقون الان نحن الذين بحاجه لان يكون
لديهم موقف واحد وحاسم هل هو بالنسبه لهم
فعليا انتهت شرعيه نظام السفاح نحن الان
لماذا نحن بحاجه الى الشرعيه لان هذا دليل
واقعي وواضح على نزع خطا غطاء شرعيه لم لم
تكن موجوده من الاساس لهذا النظام القاتل
المجرم فاذا الان نحن ايضا بحاجه الى ان
نختبر المجتمع الدولي لا اعتقد ان انهم
بحاجه لان تتاخر انا لذلك انا قلت يمكن
البدايه من ملف الجرحى لان ملف جرحه
بامكانهم ان يذهبوا هم الى تلك الدول وان
يحملوا هذه هذ هذه هذه الملفات هم ليسوا
بحاجه الى جسم قيادي يفرض السيطره على
الارض ومع ذلك اقول عملنا بالاغ اثه انا
اتحدث كحراك ثوري الهيئه العامه للثوره
السوريه ولجان التنسيق المحليه عملنا شهور
على المستوى الاغاثه وهناك شبكات على على
المستوى العسكري نقطه مهمه ايضا المساله
العسكريه استاذ حسان الهاشمي هل هو قادر
على هذا الائتلاف على ضبط المشهد العسكري
على خلق قياده مركزيه تضبط الامور عسكريا
وهي في يعني في اغلبها مثل ما قالت في
البدايه يعني نشهد تشكل دكاكين لامراء حرب
وكل له سلاحه لكل معابر سلاحه وهل هذا
الائتلاف اليوم قادر على ان يضبط هذه
المساله على الارض دعيني بدايه يعني انا
اؤكد انه ال يعني احنا اساسا لما صار في
الانتقال الى قضيه الدفاع عن النفس وبدات
موضوع العسكره في في في في الصوره الثوره
ك كلها ابتداء ايه كان اي يعني هذا هذا
هذا هذا واحده من من التحديات التي هي
بدات من من من من من من لا شيء يعني لم
يكن في لدينا من قبل خبره او او او او
يعني خميره لبدايه هذه الاعمال فهذه
القضايا عندما تبدا من لا من من لا شيء
يكون فيها مشاكل في بدايتها هذا امر طبيعي
وتتطور مع الوقت لكن طبعا في الموضوع
العسكري تكون عاده اخطر من غيرها فحتى
نشوء هذه الحالات في في في الحاله الثوريه
السوريه كانت تعتبر حاله طبيعيه بالنسبه
للتحدي الذي كان موجود يعني نحتاج لشيء من
الواقعيه في في النظر الى هذه القضيه
القضيه نشات ليس لان الناس يعني عندها
رغبه في الفوضى ولا هي ف سيئه في ذاتها
ذكرنا ايضا الجانب الدور او المسؤوليه
الدوليه في قضيه التعاطي معهم في
موضوع المساعدات لم تعتمد اجسام مركزيه
بجديه وبحسم من اجل ان لا تنشا هذه حالات
فهذه حالات نشات لاسباب موضوعيه كانت يعني
هي سبب وراء هذا هذا الامر الان نحن نريد
وباستمرار على مدار الوقت كان في هناك
محاولات لانشاء مجالس عسكريه مركزيه
ولتوحيد العمل العسكري طبعا قد تكون
التجارب انجح في بعض الاماكن منها في
اماكن اخرى على سبيل المثال في حلب الان
المجلس العسكري الثوري كان قادر على توحيد
الكتائب وفي التعاطي معها طبعا سيكون في
هناك باستمرار فرصه للتطوير هذا ما في شك
منه اذا على في في في بالنسبه لمقدر
الائتلاف على متابعه هذا الامر وتاكيده
و يعني تطمين من من هم القلقين حول هذه
القضيه انا ما عندي شك ابدا انه هذا امر
سياخذ ايضا حجمه هو احد الاهداف سؤال سؤال
هذا شي ورد في الانباء ان روسيا تدعو
الائتلاف اليوم الى الحوار مع النظام هذه
مساله مفروغ
منها الروس تدعو الائتلاف الجديد الى
الحوار مع النظام السوري روسيا دعت اليوم
الائتلاف الى الحوار طبعا هذا مخالف لما
قام عليه الائتلاف الائتلاف قام على رفض
الحوار مع النظام جمله وتفصيله طيب مارك
جوتن في واشنطن ما ينتظره تنتظره الثوره
السوريه والشعب السوري اليوم من الغرب
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه هو دعم اغاثي
ومساعدات ودعم عسكري وما زلنا نتحدث دائما
عن وعود ليس هناك اعتراف حتى الان مجرد
ترحيب هل يعني هناك من يفسر الموقف الغربي
على انه يعني محاوله لا اضعاف الطرفين
المدني والعسكري من اجل اضعاف الجميع ثم
في النهايه تقديم مشروع او مسوده حل يرضى
بها يقترحها الغرب وتفرض على الطرف الضعيف
في النهايه ما رايك في هذا
الكلام حسب معلوماتي بالناس الذين على
الارض والذين يمثلون الحكومه الامريكيه
واناس اخرون هنا اتصل بهم والسوريون ايضا
الذين يشاركون مع هذا المجلس لا اعتقد ان
هذه القضيه على الاطلاق لكن اعتقد ان
القضيه حقا هي عباره عن عمليه تركيز على
النصر الفعال والكفؤ للشعب السوري وهذا
النصر الكفؤ الفاعل سيكون تضامن بين الناس
بتخطي للخطوط عرقيه والطائفيه ب من خلال
تحالف وائتلاف واضح يمكن للولايات المتحده
ان تستثمر به بانه حاكم مستقبلي لسوريا
هذا هو المفتاح للتغيير الاجتماعي وادرك
ان العنف الهائل فرض على هؤلاء الناس
واستخدم وكان امرا مشكلا على الغرب بان
يكون هناك اي توافق على دعم عسكري بسبب
الانقسامات بين القوى العظمى ولكن ليس
هناك انقسامات متعلقه بتقديم المساعدات
وتقويه
الائتلاف نعم الذي يهتم بالمدنيين وب
الحاكميه المستقبليه لسوريا
شكرا شكرا جزيلا
لك نعتذر للمقاطعه لضيق الوقت انتهى وقت
البرنامج شكرا جزيلا لك مارك جوتن استاذ
دراسات تسويه النزاعات في جامعه جورج
ميسون بالولايات المتحده الامريكيه وكان
معنا في الاستديو الشكر لضيفنا سهير
الاتاسي نائب رئيس الائتلاف الوطني السوري
وايضا للاستاذ حسان الهاشمي عضو الائتلاف
الوطني السوري شكرا جزيلا لكم وبهذا تنتهي
حلقتنا من برنامج ما وراء الخبر اطب المنى
والى
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اللقاء
ه